the change in the world today is the
availability of immense data as a matter
of fact every individual has a digital
footprint and by looking at that
footprint you can pretty much tell what
drives them that's new when I went to
school it was all about I have so little
data therefore let me come up with the
fanciest tools to get as much
information out of it today it is about
I have so much data how do I get to
figuring out what does that data tell
you and I think that's the shift those
are the new Sciences and here's the
problem with data
Pramod data is I can do a lot off
garbage in garbage out I can look at
data and say here's the relationship
between this and this and that doesn't
mean the one thing causes the other it's
just that the two are linked so a lot of
the data Sciences are about this is
correlated with this and therefore I'm
gonna assume they're related I'm gonna
assume they're correlated and that one
drives the other but that's not the case
that can be pretty dangerous so the best
new techniques get at the concept of
causality what causes what that's what I
really want to know in data and when you
get to thinking about causality
causality is usually some human behavior
that's driving that and so the
confluence of behavioral economics and
behavioral sciences that tells you this
is how humans behave and taking that
together with data and try to create
these behavioral causal models is really
the holy grail of data analysis and
that's an art you cannot some machines
and people can do it due to a great
extent but the last mile is always about
understanding that human behavior so
today it's still an art it's a very
powerful art but the benefit of that is
that you can actually aid individuals
and saying you know this is what's
driving this behavior or this is what's
driving what you're doing and by the way
do you want to correct that or keep
doing what you're doing and that's so
important in the world
of Finance because people tend to
procrastinate sometimes they don't need
to look so far ahead as they should
these kind of Sciences can add a lot to
helping individuals and their financial
needs as an example when you look at
data and we look at what drives people
and how they behave there are so many
different types one thing we can be sure
off is that it's a rarity to find sort
of the the rational Adam Smith
individuals there are fewer of those
than people think everybody has some
different ways of behaving but there's
so many of them for example take a
number and you may say 50 and if I
follow up that with a question of how
many people do you think are in this
building it turns out your mind
gravitates to 50 and the answer is
pretty close to 50 that's called
anchoring what you just heard influences
what you say and what your judgments are
all about that's a big bias the other
kind of biases you see as people have
invariably in huge impatience factors
meaning that you value that coffee right
now a lot more than 10 coffees tomorrow
so it's another factor which is instant
gratification is something people want
to pay for and they pay for a lot and
they will defer things like savings as
an example as a result of that you know
you you get into conformity biases when
when you know you believe in something
and you don't say you believe in it but
it's implicit in what you're doing when
you go do analysis you search for the
data that confirms what you believe and
then you say I've got this data that
shows this is right well turns out well
you are looking for it so there are
eight nine ten of these things there are
many of these things and it doesn't mean
that somebody's doing something wrong
it's just the way we're wired sometimes
in just the way we think and the more
you expose it the better off we're gonna
be as individuals to think about whether
we should count or shouldn't counter or
shouldn't counter it at least you need
to have that choice so knowing what the
bias
our I think it's important knowing which
individuals have which bias and making
that clear to them and transparent I
think that's important too
having said that people need to choose
to counter these biases doesn't always
happen so you've got all kinds of health
apps that tell you you know this is
what's happening should you be doing
this and guess what people still do it
sometimes so modification of behavior is
a tougher challenge than just knowing
that your behavior is driving certain
things but having said that there are
some very clever ways of doing it and
that's where this art of behavioral
science and economics come in it's not
about saying hey you're a rational
person this is irrational behavior you
should be doing this if it was you would
have probably already done it it's about
how you create the right nudges and the
right kind of incentives to drive people
to do the right thing
sometimes is about you know is this
behavior that you have right for your
kids and you know that sometimes tell
tilts how people start behaving so the
art still lies and how you take that
information and turn that into nudges
and other prompts that get people to
counter the behavior
you